a lot of [ __ ]
who's taking it to a whole new level man
Lee this [ __ ] car man
Rochester New York is gonna get okay get
it
hmm quite a pack job there dude thanks
bro
yeah you should work for Hewlett Packard
plating Green Bay packing this car to
the next venue George Luke the card is
here let me see if it's in focus
you
could be on TV kind of freaking us out
yeah he's got this camera one of those
of MTV showed jackass community none
said Kehoe performing this weekend at
the comedy club Cheyenne Obama
I know everybody's walking our Bob how
about that [ __ ] [ __ ] did nothing
right what do we know about the person
whose head this is oh I think he was a
Filipino it doesn't get much more legit
than this right like this can't even be
legal now it's back to bed
Oh
always got it take your hands away
here remember you sign my leg that's
your dick dude it is a good-looking dick
that's some of my best work I wish I get
tattooed on your question you ate a
cheese plate I was gonna really
even though he his date
leave okay here we go
as shitty tattoos that suck terribly go
this is pretty awesome and I'm not even
gonna charge you we just saw the hateful
eight
let's see a bunch of bottled water thank
you and then yes
yeah then yeah associated me came down
dropping of Korea taking so much brother
so that all weekend making videos like
this is a lot of [ __ ] work and if you
want us to keep doing it respect the
like button right now ah [ __ ] we did it
we did it